to Can he not imagine living with a woman if she's not a stall
for him? That's that's basically what he's saying. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, the way that he talks about women, he obviously
doesn't have a very high opinion of them, right?
True. It's like quite disgusting that he doubled down on the
stuff he said about denim. I don't know. Yeah. It's just like,
oh, these women are they're only good for being only fans and
are good enough for listening to despite the fact that nothing
like cohesive or intelligent comes out of his mouth, but he doesn't
have the benefit of also being attractive. So, he's got neither.
Ming takes shots at Tect after he joined kick. Just a reminder,
this dude supports his father who's a not true and got an anime
tattoo. Absolutely true. Absolutely true. feel bad. But he is
a man and he is loud.
Allegedly. What do you mean allegedly? You're not sure he's a
man.
Really? Surely if I asked for like the third time why Tik Tok
got banned
Uh that's a part of the the thing today, Kelly is we're going
to go try to figure that out. It looks like he said something
to just a minkx. Did that I don't know if he got banned for that
or not. I don't know if that was what caused him to get banned.
Yeah. So, I'm guessing through the course of the story, we will
actually we'll actually be able to figure it out. Let's check
it out. So, what was this? Trump and Elon thing. You went to
the end to do a teaser for it. Yeah, he just does sometimes.
But I don't know the answer. If I knew the answer, I would tell
you. So, it's not about spoilers. You could have just said I
don't know then, you stupid. And then someone else could have
told me.
Okay, here. I'll just wait for somebody to tell me in chat. I'm
watching chat. What did uh what did Tech say, guys? Or what what
how did he get banned? Does anybody know
for calling someone a [__] Okay. Was it like a one
day? It kind of been a long ban for calling sevenday ban.
Depends who he called a [__] I suppose if it was
another Twitch partner, it might be why it was that long.
I look forward to him complaining that Hosan only got banned
for one day. Oh, he called Minkx a so it might have been in the
Just a Mink stuff if we'd gone and watched that.
But now we know it's he calls just a mink a Oh, and denims fairy
based. Okay. Uh Minkx takes shots at Techone after he joined
kick.
Just a reminder that this dude supports his father who's a and
got an anime tattoo to feel better after essaying and degrading
his past two partners. But okay. Yes, he got a berserk tattoo.
He got a cringe berserk tattoo. Yes, he got the the berserk tattoo
on his shoulder. Why? and talk started talking about how he's
like um he's being put through like a trial and he'll come out
the other side like guts. He's he thinks he's like guts because
um I don't I actually don't know why. He's kind of the most cringe
person on Twitch right now. Most person said it was because there's
a horse in Berserk.
There is a horse in Berserk. Yes. Yep. Yep. Uh so I think so
Mix also replied and linked No, she tweeted and linked the Shamu
documentary. Shout out Shamu runs in the family. Techone, Twitch's
most abusive liar. I've had bad interactions with him myself
in in private, but this video really will shine some light to
the viewers. Wow. So, and then Techone did a little bit of an
on-stream response, which I'm guessing the source of how he got
banned. Minkx is mad about what?
Minkx is mad. Minkx takes shots. Minkx takes shots at Tecton
after he joined kick. Just a reminder, this dude supports his
father who's a Not true. And got an anime tattoo. Absolutely
true. Absolutely true. Feel better after essaying and degrading
his past. Yeah, that's the tattoo right there, Kelly.
You got that tattoo, partners. But okay, never happened. Let
me take this. Uh, it's just this one right here on his shoulder,
but it's it kind of slides in and out of frame. takes shots like
every
alcoholics. How the We'll get a chance to see it at some point
here. Somebody will link the tweet, the cringe tweet. Oh my god.
Alcoholics.
He sounds so drunk trying to type this. Uh he's like mocking
her for being an alcoholic while sounding like an alcoholic himself.
a nonair missing she goes to
uh I just want you to know I said that joke yesterday is a stolen
we ban Ruben donated $3 runs in the family a DNA more like DSA
am I right I don't runs in the family DNA more like DSA am I
right I think some people get it and I don't but cool I don't
get it listen I'm slow today so and I do say that a So, you know,
it's starting to become a pattern. DSA stands for Democratic
Socialist of
I don't know. I don't know. I don't get it. Uh, right click through.
He's talking about Minkx. What's this? I've had bad interaction
with him myself in private, but this video will shine some light
of viewers.
What? Mix, I've seen you one
time outside of Miz Kip's house during my OTK debut where I said,
"I got no idea who you are, but you're Schlatt's girlfriend,
right?" And you were actually nothing but kind. And then you,
you know, well, you got wasted again underneath medication at
the party. Minkx, are there anybody else in the room right now?
Are there any other humans in the room right now?
Are there anybody else now that you've had bad interactions with?
Can you Are you muted? So he's so ridiculous. Sorry. He just
he uh I don't know what he took before this stream to sound like
this
Um Minkx, are there anybody else in the room right now? Minkx,
can you answer? I didn't catch that at first. Jerry, are there
any other humans in the room right now that you've had bad interactions
with? I didn't I thought you were like mocking him at first.
I didn't catch it. Can you see them? What are they saying? Sorry.
I thought you were mocking him with your own thing. Good lord.
Woman, take your hand off the bottle for two seconds. For two
seconds. I mean, Jesus Christ, what a
dude. Anyways, uh easy slam dunk. Uh yeah. Yo guys, here you
go. Uh indie game showcase. Uh let me check. Techone bad. Also
true. Cool. That hurt her feelings. Great. She'll drown it in
a bottle of whiskey anyways. Doesn't matter. Uh indie game showcase.
Jesus. So, I didn't call I didn't hear her call him a there or
sorry, I didn't Yeah, I didn't hear him call her a [__]
Did he do that somewhere there or was it another tweet that got
him?
Did either of you guys hear that?
Uh, no.
He basically originally maybe it was Denim's
then not Jinx.
Not here. Maybe it was Denims. True. Not in this VOD. It doesn't
look like we got a clip. Someone's got a clip for me. Base. Thank
you. Yep. Dude, let me tell you, man. Mental Jack Daniels recipe.
Okay. This is a different day. This is the next day or something.
Different shirt. Went from the US flag wife beater to the army
camo shirt base. for
Yeah. You want to know why she didn't respond to that? Because
she know her ass got I'll be real, bro. Minkx is such a nasty
[__] I wouldn't that with Russell's I'm good, bro.
Oh, well that's that'll be where it was. That'll be it right
there. Jesus Christ.
Christ. Did he forget he was streaming on Twitch at the time
or what? I don't know. I don't know if he was Wait, was he streaming
on Twitch at the time? I actually don't know. It could have been
platform conduct anyway, but uh Oh, right. Twitch will get you
for crossplatform harassment.
Yeah, they will.
Absolutely not. Hell no, bro. You can track like every single
bro. Like you have with Minkx and then your STD list starts to
look like one of these Pokedex dio uh Pokedex bios in Twitter.
You know what I'm saying? Like
chlamydia slash like some flag for representing crabs. You know
what I'm saying? And like 18 other
I don't even remotely understand the joke, but descriptors. Yeah,
she caught them all. Yeah, she caught them all, guys. But Oh,
that's that's what he was trying to get to. She caught them all.
That's what he was trying to say. He just wanted to say she caught
them all and then he realized he couldn't remember what a Pokédex
looks like. It's not Pokemon that she caught.
Yeah. Okay. I get Somebody gave him the Pokemon joke about somebody
catching all the STDs and he totally flubbed trying to make that
joke cuz he knew the punchline he wanted to get to. She caught
them all. She's like, "Ash, catch them." Okay. But with STDs,
she caught them all. He was trying to do something like that.
Unfortunately, he's not funny. That's going around recently.
He's more likely to, huh? Yeah, be owning that. Yeah. Oh, guys,
yes, you're allowed to ban or sorry, you're allowed to stream
any banned user. You just cannot stream their live content. You
can absolutely stream clips of them, do whatever you want with
their stuff, but uh you just can't stream them live, reream them,
or have them on your stream live, I think, if they're banned,
but you can watch their old. There's nothing that Twitch used
to be like that. They totally changed it. Okay. And oh, I was
gonna show this one as well that this is um this is coming from
this. Technone won't respond to this. And DK again using the
most picture of Tees X that he possibly could to get as many
views as he can. Wow. Uh and sorry, I wanted to show that show
Chud's video just because Tech comes in and says, "So, can we
still drop Tomato Town or And this was posted, I believe, within
like within like 10 minutes of Chud's video dropping." So Teone
has the Chud subs on, right? Or got it linked by somebody and
commented within 10 minutes of this video dropping. Well, the
title says Teone won't respond to this. So I guess Yeah, I guess
that's why he replied directly.
This is a fragile ego comment.
I He's got a lot of those. So yes, I I believe so. Right. Like
he's he's done that a lot. We've looked at a couple different
instances of him doing that. So I think that's exactly what it
is. Fragile ego.
If he does not
There you go.
I was gonna say if he doesn't play if he doesn't play Fortnite
with Chun and admit that he's like a huge fan of his reviews,
uh, this is fake.
What I was going to ask is was this guy always like this or was
he like more likable before he I don't know last couple years
or whenever he blew up? I'm not sure.
He's part of the OTK house, so probably always like this. Oh,
hold on. What the is reviews?
What the
he was worse? So, we already know that he's not a fan, Cherry.
We already know.
Okay, it's clear. No, not true. Not true. That was a Hmbo moment.
Before he ever said that on stream, he was definitely in Chud's
chat. That's why he said the thing about Tomato Town at Tomato
Town because he was in Chud's chat during a review telling Chud
that they need to play Fortnite or something. I think he he definitely
knew who Chud was. Yeah. And also I think he's just like very
used to, you know, given his proclivities. He's just very like,
"No." Oh my god. He's got to pretend he doesn't know. I mean,
he previewed his own dad. Just because he didn't call it a preview
doesn't mean it wasn't.
I don't think he did. He said I think it's the opposite where
he Yeah, he said he didn't find out until Hassan said something.
Yes, but then he went into it and how apparently all of the women
were like it was exaggerated and blah blah blah. He did review
his dad. He didn't not talk about it. He went into the details
of it. That was his choice and decided to liar. Yes. Diminish
uh the stories of the women involved. That's like literally what
he did.
His ex-girlfriend makes a comment saying how the his dad like
said that those girls were lying and stuff like that. So, it's
there's no chance that he didn't know that his dad did that stuff
before the time that he said that he found out.
Yeah, I'm uh devious about timeline. Very concerning. I've not
seen like really meaningful uh also oh I actually should point
this out with this video that I believe the he won't respond
to this is
basically a review of past techone drama. So this is the Shimu
video right? So I think what what the title is meant to be saying
is Tone will not respond to the Shimu drama video because he
is scared. But I get that that is probably he probably thinks
oh I will respond. I will message or I will send a thing here.
Haha haha. He's so clever,
guys. Because this is all in the backdrop. Uh, Kelly, you weren't
here, but here, I'll actually I'll show No, I I did see a bit
of it where he went and spoke to Chud because he basically called
Chel
different different Kelly. I'm I'm trying to tell you about uh
the video. Oh, it's not. Dude, what is what is Shimu's YouTube
at? I'm just saying I know I know the original backstory. I don't
know who Shamu is. Yeah. Yeah. So Shimu made a video that basically
walks through the timeline and exposes Teone like super hard
for lying about a bunch of stuff with his assault cases assault
case and like his uh lawsuit with his previous wife. And this
like Shimu was talking to him. This the guy who made the video
was talking to Tect and as soon as Teone become aware that Shamu
was like way more informed than he
uh way more informed than he expected then he immediately cut
off Shamu stopped talking to him. Just totally stopped responding.
So, this is like a video that goes through this stuff like extensively.
Came out four days ago. We reviewed it on stream. I'm just trying
to catch up so you know that when we watch uh when we, you know,
watch some other stuff around TechOne. That's We're talking about
the What was the top thing the Shamu guy exposed him for? Like
what was the most egregious lie Tech told? What was the most
uh he So, it just exposed the timeline on how you know when he
had that abusive conversation with his with his ex-wife in the
car. Dude, I am the conflict resolution god.
He's a consent resolution god. Conflict resolution. But oh, consent
to I keep forgetting. Yeah.
Fighting. I mix these people up. Okay. So, what was the timeline
importance? Did he lie about like that he basically told people?
Yes, he told people that the reason he was his m that mad at
his wife that day was that he just found out she was cheating.
uh his wife hadn't even met the person that she cheated with
until like a month later and this is now proven in the video
to show that he just blatantly lied about it. I'd say that's
probably one of the worst ones. Um otherwise it's just he like
tries to intimidate these women and stuff and just like an [__]
overall.
I'd say that's like one of the biggest lies, direct lies. But
there are some other direct lies too. I can't remember off the
top of my head. That's that's the one to me where it's like,
"No, I'm not abusive, guys. I just found out my wife was cheating
on me." Oh, no, no, no. Sorry. The worst one was that um I think
he convinced his ex-girlfriend to basically come up and make
a statement against his ex-wife because he cheated on his ex-wife
with that girl, but I think he convinced the girlfriend that
the ex-wife was like sharing revenge of the that girlfriend and
techone to like get back at them. And and now the the ex-girlfriend
and the ex-wife are kind of working together and the ex-girlfriend
is like, "No, no, no. He never showed me it or showed me proof
of it. He just said it." So, I think you get them to go after
each other that the women involved will never speak to each other.
You can only lie to them for so long before they start putting
two and two together and then they're like, "Wait, this is not
adding up. This guy's being a weirdo." And inevitably, guys that
are abusive to the previous partners will start being to you
and they always do. Yep. Yep. Okay. Are we good to This is This
is Tech's video on his ban. He just released it today. Just now.
Twitch banned me over this blatant hypocrisy. Blatant hypocrisy.
Um, so I I'm thinking he's going to try to analyze in a vacuum
like his comments. Now, maybe Minkx is bad, but he's going to
try to analyze his comments in a vacuum and say like, "Oh, just
saying she has STDs, that's not enough to get other people banned.
They've said bad things about me." But he's had warnings like,
"Hey, the harassment against other Twitch partners is like a
problem from you. You need to stop." So, I think he's going to
try to analyze his behaviors. If he's not gotten warnings from
Twitch on this exact front, like, "Hey, you can't say these insane
inflammatory things about women. Not cool. Not what we want for
our brand. Please stop." He's been asked this already, right?
So, we'll watch the video. Look where we're at once again. Yep,
you read the title, right? I have been banned for the third time
in about 60 days. This one looks like it's going to be my longest
ban yet. Yes, it looks like I will be banned for seven long days
on Twitch. Will they let me appeal it? I don't know. But I assure
you when I tell you when I tell you why I've gotten banned, man,
I bet you're going to think, "Wow, that's completely justified.
Wow, that really makes sense." Yeah, it definitely won't be hypocritical
and preferential treatment towards people on the far left. Once
again, yes. If you want to do me a favor, I will be streaming
every single day at 9:00 a.m. CST on YouTube. What does this
have to do with the far left?
I don't think you could get away with saying that about any woman.
Son is bad. I don't Why do guys who wear white blazers look like
they date? This looks like the date uniform. This looks like
I carry ruies when I go to clubs uniform.
Yes, it goes it pairs very nicely with the like overall like
I forcibly face and body type and clothing otherwise the gold
chain the the black white beater underneath just everything else
about him. Yeah. So, you know, he's got multiple multiple vectors
of are totally handled right now. Yes. Yes. Exactly.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I don't know why he's trying to sell this as
like a political movement. It's just he said a bunch of unhinged
things and they have this in their toos. And it might be that
those audiences are more likely to report and other audiences
aren't as likely to report denims or whoever. Uh you I don't
know what it's going to be. We'll see. We have to see the evidence.
So like how I'm assuming he's going to have some evidence to
make this argument with. Right. I think when a big streamer makes
comments like that, it's going to get seen by Twitch staff regardless
of who's reporting. It's pretty irrelevant at that point. It's
like if you're getting thousands of views and you say unh [__]
it will get seen. Yep. My description and the pin comment a follow
on that stream would be genuinely incredibly helpful as well
as tune into the YouTube live stream. And uh the most important
thing, please subscribe to my channel and turn the bell on for
all notifications. This has been the most successful past 75
days of my career ever. Um I have gained over 80,000 subscribers
in a short 70 days. I am upcoming on 900,000. And you know what
comes next? 1 million. It's been a dream of mine for over 7 million
to eventually hit that number. And it's crazy because I think
it actually might finally be attainable. For seven years, I've
been trying to get this. And uh it's thanks to a lot of people
like Asmin Gold who shouted out my kick channel and I gained
8,000 follows in 5 minutes, which was insane. Hassanabi for being
a perpetual dumbass and allowing me to farm him for the past
three weeks and gaining over I think I've gained about
Yeah. Allow allowing me to farm him. Remember when he basically
started crying and then saying I was raped as a child in response
to Hassan saying your dad literally got like exposed on C-SPAN
for being a a military. His response was I was raped as a child.
No. And then he cried.
He said twice.
Twice. True. I used to wait twice as a child. Yes. Yep. And my
dad tried to kill me. And then he shook it off. It was like a
smile on his face and say he was going to farm his son. Yeah.
What I don't understand is if you know that your dad is a piece
of because he seems to be aware that his dad is a piece of why
would you use him as an example in anything ever? Why would you
speak about him at all?
I don't get it. It's bizarre. Don't know. Is his dad on a list?
Um, I don't think so. I think he got off super light. I think
he barely served any time. I think he got I think he was allowed
to retire with like full pension, full full everything, full
benefits from the military. Yeah, I think he basically got nothing.
What?
I'm pretty sure, unless I'm misunderstanding, I'm pretty sure.
Was he born and raised in Texas? Because do they have like a
a list that they have to register offenders? Um I don't know
where they're are they from Texas? I actually they must be from
Texas, right? I mean there is a video of the judge reading out
all the stuff that this guy's dad did, right? So that's immortalized
forever.
I don't think he's going to get away from it. But yeah, I don't
think he's specifically on the defender list.
Yeah. Yeah. 25,000 subs off of just Assan content alone, which
really isn't that much, but it still is quite nice. And most
importantly, just the overall perpetual cycle of on the internet
that I get to make content of every single day because here at
twitch.tv/techone,
youtube.com/teone,
kick.com/teone, we make a living off of making fun of dumb people.
It's great. Now, let's go ahead and get this out of the way.
Please like the video, please leave a comment, and share this
with your friends. And by the way, if you are a streamer reacting
to this or a YouTuber reacting to this sits around making fun
of himself all day. Yeah, I missed what he said to be honest
with you, Kelly. So I don't even know what you're saying. He
said spend all day making fun of dumb people.
Oh, I see. Wow. Yes, that's his content apparently. Friends,
and by the way, if you are a streamer reacting to this react
to this, I fully consent to this and I greatly encourage it.
He tries to punch down. Instead, he punches himself in the face.
appreciate you sharing some light on the absolute hypocrisy of
Twitch. Now, with all that plugging out of the way, the sheer
stupidity of this all is truly mindboggling. So, I want to walk
you through the first time I ever got warned. So, to remind you
guys, the first time I ever got banned was me saying that Denim's
only good content was on her Only Fans and nobody should consider
her worth listening to, which, you know, to be honest, it was
a little bit mean, but where's the lie? The second time I got
banned, my guy just said, "I learned absolutely nothing." Yeah.
I mean, it's he's literally like he is actually just saying,
"Yeah, I know. I got banned for saying that she's like only,
you know, good as a but uh where's the lie? I'm I'm doubling
down right now after he's I Yeah, I don't know what Twitch does.
It It feels like this is with the cops. If you just like tell
the cops you don't care, you're not going to pay your tickets,
you feel really big. You can feel really good for two seconds,
but ultimately that's the state. They control everything. You're
if you don't pay your tickets, if you just say you, the law is
stupid." Yeah. They're just going to keep hitting you with the
same law over and over and over again. Who are you winning against?
I don't get it. Honestly, if he has such a repeat history of
this and the lack of learning and the indignant behavior, I'm
genuinely surprised Twitch haven't banned him permanently. Someone
is being very lenient to this guy in my opinion.
Oh, well was and this one I believe I believe it was the second
or the third. I'm trying to remember the fir the first time I
ever got banned I believe was for telling a Twitch channel to
kill themselves which to be completely honest that was completely
justified. I was reacting to anime. I told them to put a shotgun
in their mouth and kill themselves. And to be fair, totally reasonable.
I absolutely wear that wear that man as a badge of dishonor because
I went over the deep end that day. I was very grumpy to be fair
and I was I had a really big tummy ache. Oh. Oh, I thought he
was doubling down again. He's I see tummy ache. He's saying,
"Yeah, you can b me for that." I see. I got it. I got it, too.
But I have not ever told a chatter to kill themselves since then.
I have learned from my mistake. Now, the next time I got banned
was me calling everybody's favorite streamer, Froggen, fat. Now,
I want to remind you that Froggen is roughly 5'2 and roughly
300 lb. So, I got banned for a descriptor. I called Krogan fat.
I get banned for two weeks. It gets appealed down to two days.
There's no way she's roughly 300
Uh, she's not. She also lost some weight. I don't Yeah, he he
Is it shocking that this guy would have no idea what like weight
looks like on a woman? No, not shocking. Uh, she could be like
23,24. I I can't see her being 250. Was she really 250 at some
point? Did she say that or something? I just can't see that on
like her frame. It's just she would literally have to be the
person in Willy Wonka in the Chocolate Factory who like blew
up as a blueberry if she was like that short and that fat.
Yeah. Yeah. People just don't know. Yeah. What it looks like.
18 hours roughly. Um and by the way, this is after her saying
that all American soldiers deserve PTSD and as well as America
deserve 9/11. Yes. Oh, by the way, um she didn't get banned for
that.
Wait. Yeah. Wait, what? Did she not get banned for the uh American
soldiers PTSD thing? Oh, wait. No, no, no. That's a different
for that one. I think it did result in her getting a ban, right?
She got banned right at that time. Did she get banned for something
else? There were two things she got that people were like, "Oh,
I think she's gonna get banned for this." I thought she got banned
for that one for sure. Wait, people are saying she did. I'm positive
there was a ban for the panel. The 30-day ban was for the panel.
Yes. But I could I could have sworn she got a a ban for the soldiers
deserve PTSD comment that she ate like a a small ban for that.
Yeah, I think that ban happened before the other ban. I don't
know why it's from Times of India, but the streamer Frogan found
herself at the center of a controversy being handed a 30-day
spent on the platform. The ban follows the circulation of a clip.
She definitely got banned for 30 days, but this is what October
22, 2024. I don't think it was for this her I don't think she
got another 30-day ban. I don't think she got two 30-day bans.
This this if but if it was October 22nd, I remember it being
a ban that over overlapped with the election. So, wait, did she
get 30 days and the other people got seven? Yes. didn't. Yeah,
other people got less days than her. Remember? I I don't remember.
That's the unfortunate thing. Uh I do remember
Yeah, they all got 30. Okay, never mind. Maybe I'm I thought
these happened distinctly. I thought these were like apart. Although,
I wouldn't be shocked if this helped her and all of her friends
get banned to be honest.
Band-aids.
It is so weird being uh a leftist and hoping people get PTSD.
Yeah. No, that's [__] up. I think the other one was
like a three or seven day ban. Yeah. I did not think she um she
like especially when most of your chat has a panic attack leaving
the house. You know what I mean? Yeah. She didn't get banned
for it. Yeah. It doesn't look like like I guess you could say
that they weren't going to double ban her when they banned her
for like right around this time because it was around the same
time.
Yeah. But if she got no increased time, then I could see why
people would say she didn't get banned for it. That would make
some sense. God. And all of those content creators, they couldn't
cover the election because of this, right? Yeah. Yeah. Because
of the
panel. It's called a perma. That's all they had to do. You think
she should be banned permanently for that comment?
No. Funky Boss. I I think it's insane to say she should be banned
permanently for that comment.
That comment's up, by the way. But for it to be a perma ban is
crazy. Like it does damage to yourself. Yeah, like your brand
overall. I just hate her. Yeah, but that's not the that's not
the means or the measure by which we say people should be banned,
bro. You can't just hate people and want them b Well, you can
reel in them getting banned. You shouldn't call for them to get
banned for stupid or else other people will get banned.
Exactly. And I understand maybe not liking her politics or something
or not liking the streamer she supports, but Fergen is funny.
No, she's not. She's literally not funny. No, she's not. Yeah,
she's hilarious. That's the one moment she's ever had a personality
on stream. That's not fair. That's not fair. That's not fair
to take the one moment she's ever been.
Uhhuh. Okay. Well, I got you. I got you, Frogan. I don't know
you, Frogan, but you owe me one.
Why do you ride Hassan so much? Have I mentioned Hassan here?
Where did that guy hear Hassan? Your name has Hassan jacks off
to Asminold. It seems like you might be the problem here. Not
me. Han is bad. Han is bad. Hassan is bad. Hassan is good. Hassan
is good. Hassan is bad. Han is bad. Hassan is neither good or
bad. He's just Hassan.
Hassan is like deeply deeply good.
I hate prescribing moralness to any Twitch streamers because
I don't know them. Wow. Yeah. I don't I literally don't understand
why the
What are we That guy brought up a song. Yeah. I'm so confused
right now.
People what they want. Do we have a song content? He didn't say
anything else.
He just said that and then he um and then he bounced. Crazy.
I was gonna give him a second, but
well,
depends what your definition of bad is, I suppose.
Dude, I don't have anything to chew today. I ate yesterday.
Okay. What do we got next? Oh, we are only 4 minutes into this
video. Let's continue. Now, let's talk about why I got banned
this time. Well, it's actually due to two streamers, not one,
but two. Uh, and this is great. So, here it is. 7day suspension
for request, graphic, or derogatory statements or unwanted content.
And you might be wondering, oh, techie techie techie, what did
you do this time? Well, there are two streamers who have been
really talking about me for months. Actually, what's crazy is
talking about me for years and their names are Denims and Minks.
Yeah. Oh, man. You know where this is going, guys. So, this is
a whole clip of uh Denims mocking my trauma about worrying about
my father when I told a story about how when he was deployed,
he got his legs the the skin of his legs completely blown off
as well as his ear cut off in the war. and her laughing in my
You really think that if this were the case, he would have had
a harder time like cornering all of those women. This guy somehow
got all the skin blown off of his legs and he's mobile as how
did he make that work face and saying that he deserved it and
that I probably made up the entire story. Which war? It's got
to be golf one, right? Meatwusty. It's got to be golf one. I
think
skin grows back. It does grow back. That's true.
That's the first play. Here's the second one. Yeah. This is Denims
calling me a predator on kick.
Very fun. Where does it say predator? Did it say that?
Kick. Recruiting a pest during pride month is so brave. Oh, pest.
Yeah. Doesn't say predator. Oh boy. You can't read either.
No boy. On kick.
Unfortunately, you've got some credible allegations of this,
Mr. Teone. That's the unfortunate thing for you. Credible allegations
that you've used lies that are now being exposed to distract
from and to try to cover up. That's the issue. I don't think
Denims is saying anything incorrect
here. Or you could just review the Shimu video and explain why
you weren't lying. Just remove just review the Shimu video. That's
all you got to do. Techone. Review it. Review the video. We're
playing like fest. Yeah, it's uh
very fun to a total of time of recording
47,000 people. But if we go further, it actually reached 1 million
people. And trust me, Denims and I have a very shady history
because I don't know why this woman is absolutely obsessed with
me. Now, here is Denims once again calling me a and saying I
can't sue her because it's not defamation because in her words,
I did that.
The reason Teetone can't sue me is because he did that. And there's
a whole bunch of other goodies in that clip. Where's the part
where she's like, I can call him a Did she call him a
Uh, she probably did call him a but I don't I don't know. I I
He hasn't played it, but she must What is she saying this to?
You spend like weeks making hate videos in Techton like his personal
situation with his ex blah blah blah art of your life, part of
your life, but you wanted to damage his reputation/life for views.
So, as his life went to, you profited off of it. So, you're advocating
that he sues you for defamation next.
Oh, maybe she was arguing. She doesn't even say that she called
him over. She's talking about the allegations.
talking about the that other women have said that he's done.
Oh, since she keeps advocating for per se law rules, Teone is
legally innocent until proven guilty. So, she is slandering in
the eyes of the law. Uh, what are the defamation pers rules again?
What do we defamation per se? Uh, defamation per se. Oh, okay.
Hold on. Can I get a Can I get a find law.com? Let's see what
it says here. The tort defamation. So for are you not allowed
to say that like genetically he has like the DNA of a sexual
assaulter? Uh you shouldn't probably but I do think it's funny
crimes and loathome diseases.
So basically if you say that he is guilty that's is that defamation
per se to say he's guilty of what he's accused of? You say that
like uh I can call him that cuz he's guilty. You that would be
defamation per se. It might be would it are you not allowed to
say that I believe the victims? It depends on how you say it
probably
that no I feel like there's no way you have to qualify oh I believe
the victims but he is innocent until proven like I'm pretty sure
people have gone publicly and said I believe the victims
someone else will be fine because it's not like um you don't
get the the law is not you are a pest right so it's like um
so so the argument would be this isn't about this confess comment.
This is about the uh if two people have made allegations,
right? And your opinion is that they've done it and I believe
that that's fine.
I don't I think this is defamation per se. I think this is unironically
defamation per se because what she's saying is I I can't be sued
by him because he did that. And it's like well you don't know
that yet. He's only accused. And when you say he did that, like
you're literally and you're literally saying I'm not defaming
him. I know I'm attacking his reputation, but he did it. Without
proof of that, I think you probably get in trouble here. You
have to throw in the word I believe. Yeah, I think so. Something
like that. I think so. Yeah, because in her words, I did that.
The reason Teone can't sue me is because he did that [__]
And there's a whole bunch of other goodies in that
What's up? I thought that [__] is like truth is
it is like truth beats defamation, right? It is. Yeah. But I
think one she doesn't know that right now. I don't know if she's
seen all the evidence. And two, I I don't know if there's like
So maybe they'd have to wait for the outcome of that case or
something. I have no idea. But there's no like context to what
she can't be sued for. Because if she's saying Teone can't sue
me for me saying he's a pest, she would be right because the
things that she's accusing him of doing are just whatever the
allegations are. But she's not saying what the allegations are.
She's not saying that he's so I don't think but the allegations
talking with regards the context here. the allegations are sexual
assault.
But even what she's saying right there in that comment, it doesn't
say.
Yeah, it doesn't. I don't think it's I don't think that that
would count either. So, for him to use that clip and say, "Oh,
defamation." I don't see it. Proving defamation is difficult.
So, uh that would be a waste of his time and money as well. But
I don't know. I don't think proving defamation. So, this is why
this is and we can look it up. This is probably bad for Denims
in terms of if Tech's focused on it because Denims made this
exact argument about Ethan Klein. You accused me of filing a
false report or aiding in a betting in filing a false report
to CPS. You're accusing me of a crime. You have no proof of that
crime. You're you're liable for defamation, per se.
Um, wait, but but he was Ethan was literally going on his stream
over and over. Denims did this to me. This happened to me. Denims
did this to me. this happened, right? He's making those claims
as the victim, saying this person Yeah, there's a degree of separation
here in that the allegations being made against Teone aren't
hers. It's two other women that everyone already knows about.
So, to prove defamation, she would have to be damaging his reputation
when his reputation was already damaged by the things that were
said by the two girls originally, right? So it's like how could
he prove that her statements had damaged his reputation?
Probably be difficult. Yeah. Yeah. It would be and whatever damage
he imagines happened to him. Uh finding a woman to [__]
on on stream is probably uh fixed that for him, right? All those
viewers are back. Oh, look at that. They never left.
His uh his taking off. This is why we should actually we should
actually basically say everybody who's trying to file lawsuits
against each other for talked on the internet unless it is them
explicitly like making things up about you with zero evidence,
right? You should just say, "Yeah, you don't sue over that, right?"
Like if they're exp if they're explicitly making things up that
they have no evidence for, this isn't like something they're
even like stretching a little bit. Yeah. Unless they're doing
that, off. Don't don't try to sue people is my opinion on it.
But yeah. Okay. No comments from anybody else. Okay. The reason
Techone can't sue me is because he did that [__]
And there's a whole bunch of other goodies in that clip. Yes.
I want to let you know that this woman is so obsessed with harassing
me that she is now at the point where she knows that she might
need lawyers in the very near future for slandering my name and
defaming me on a daily basis. Yes. a woman who has gone live
and attempted to call me a criminal. Call me a tell me my father
deserved to have his legs blown off in a zero. Did she call him
a criminal?
Don't like this. Uh and esports Batman said this, right? That
saying means a convicted criminal. Like no is just like a word,
right? There are plenty of people who who did not catch a charge,
did not get convicted, they were uh they weren't even reported.
They still and
sure. Um but I think this is specifically in the context of the
chatter who's talking about the I think the allegations, but
maybe maybe the chatter is bringing up the law, right? The chatter
is bringing up the law. It's like the these guys are just being
um like legal perverts.
Okay. All right. You literally say that you someone in a debate
like you know what that word has uh meaning outside of a conviction.
Yeah, sure. I would love to see like the other things that he's
saying Denim said as well. Uh which by the way, she also calls
my father a as well. Um, which is crazy because if you look into
the court documents, the only thing that happened there was no
whatsoever. So once again, also lying on the truth. I he did
this with Chud Logic and Chud called him out immediately was
like, "Okay, but you understand that like on the internet when
people say like like digitally penetrating somebody or groping
them, they'll still call you like a or say you you've done like
things, right?" Like you're you're trying to split hairs here
on something like but but like I'm sure Denims would acknowledge
your dad was not convicted of like forcibly penetrating these
women in vagina forcibly penetrating these women. That's not
what he's accused of. But like I yeah when she says like of course
this is just like uh catch all terms like which is like I I would
like if we used the totally correct thing but yeah just convicted
of assault six times. Sure.
Yeah. I mean, people say like, "Oh, that's like behavior or something,
right? It
it just has a broad scope to it." Yep.
Arguably, again, this guy's history is entirely known. So, it's
like the whole purpose of defamation is to prove some kind of
reputational damage happened. But if your reputation was already
what has been damaged?
Mhm. Yeah.
I just clicked off onto a different video. Hopefully not too
hard to find out wherever we are here. Well, is a whole laughing
at 7,000 people. But if
and saying I can't sue her because it's not defamation because
in her words, I did that. The reason Teone can't sue me is because
he did that. And there's a whole bunch of other goodies in that
clip. Yes, I want to let you know that this woman is so obsessed
with harassing me that she is now at the point where she knows
that she might need lawyers in the very near future for slandering
my name and defaming me on a daily basis. Brother, you do that
to yourself
who has he could shut up and he doesn't. And attempted to call
me a criminal. Quiet is free.
It's free. And none of these men take that as the option. They
just can't help themselves. He could shut up and he should shut
up. There we are.
Being like a gotcha streamer and wearing like a chain or a pearl
necklace necklace is weird. Weird. You could also choose not
to do that. Yeah, it's a lot of strange decisions being made.
Like pimp attire or something. What's going on here? Take your
own advice, Kelly. Well, if I ever someone then I'll be sure
to shut up.
Angelian, you remind me if that ever happens. What do you mean?
Nope. Way plays gotcha. Isn't that his whole
Okay. Yep, it is. I thought I got it confused.
No, it is totally his thing.
Call me a Tell me my father deserve to have his legs blown off
and his ears cut off. Uh, which by the way, she also calls my
father a as well.
Uh, is he talking Did he switch to Froen? Did I miss a switch
to Froen? Maybe call me a I don't know. But did anybody say his
dad deserved to get his legs blown off?
Um, they might have said I don't feel bad about it or something.
For slandering my name and defending me on a daily basis.
Yes. A woman who has gone live and attempted to call me a criminal,
call me a tell me my father deserved to have his legs blown off
and his ears cut off. Uh which by the way, she also calls my
father a as well. Um which is crazy because if you look into
the court documents, the only thing that happened there was no
whatsoever. So once again, also lying on the truth. I've also
shown documents of that on my Twitter. Wow. And the other woman
is another woman. Can you imagine that going to court?
Your honor, my father is not a He just committed multiple acts
of sexual assault. Send women to jail and even more acts of sexual
assault. Yeah, it's only 14, your honor. It's not 15 until you
hit I mean, never mind. I up
known It's not until you hit 15. Alcoholic. Yeah, I got it. Known
drug abuser. known skitso goes live on Twitter and says
reminder Teone's dad is arrested and that I also have assaulted
two women according to her. Another woman who is accusing me
of crimes. Oh, and trust me, this woman is so deranged she believes
that she's lived with me.
No. What?
I want to remind you I've met Miss I don't She might have like
been staying in the same house. Yes, she did stay with OTK for
a while, didn't she? I think Miss Kip literally had her at the
house.
Yeah. Yeah, she did. Maybe I Is he going to pretend for a while?
Is it him who's going to pretend like he didn't live with her?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Okay, actually,
he lived two doors down. He lived two doors down. They didn't
live together. He lived two doors down. I'm positive that's the
difference he's making here, right? Tone didn't live with Msk.
Techone lived like literally a like 30 second walk away from
Msk. This is literally what they didn't live together, but like
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is what people mean when they say and
are bad faith. This is bad faith.
Yeah. Yeah. My assumption would have been she either stayed with
multiple people during her stay when she was there cuz she was
trying to get a visa or some [__] wasn't she?
Or the house. Yeah, Tone had maybe like stayed with some of the
others when he was moving into the area or something. So, there
was like some level of overlap. I doubt she would just make that
up. It doesn't really make any sense.
Sides, he's saying that when you say live two doors down, you
mean you mean like two doors over in the same house, right? No,
no, no, no, no, no, no. I mean two doors. I mean like they're
literally TechTome bought the house like next to Misk's house
to go live around them. Like the OTK people all in houses together
and all did content together. They like he could say they didn't
live together, but they spent like a ton of their time hanging
out together and collabing with each other, right? Okay. But
is she is she going to be the one and imply that Two Houses Down
is living with him or Yes. Is he being oblivious and not realizing
he let her stay over for like a week and she considers that living
together for a week?
I don't So I don't know. There could be that she stayed around
him or in the same like I don't know the mechanics. I'm saying
his house was a different house that was like two doors down
and Misg helped him buy it
and that I don't know if she's in saying I lived in that area
so I lived with him. I don't know what's happening there. I have
no idea. I don't I think she stayed with multiple people.
And it just is the case that she probably did live with him for
a bit. But it's like most people might not see if they were like
staying together for a few weeks as living. That might be his
point of contention. It's like she didn't live here. She was
just staying here for I don't know. Who cares? I think they stayed
in the same house for like two weeks. Okay. So they probably
they probably did live in the same I'm guessing they did share
a house at some point. I would really care if she stayed with
him around the time where he was with, I don't know, somebody
that claimed that he was like pretty abusive
controlling. Maybe he would try to pretend like she never lived
with him if uh she was a witness to something.
Uh possibly. I don't know that she would have been a witness
though. There's definitely he's definitely kept mum about the
fact that Shamu showed those um the court docs that said that
um Sodapoppin and Vivebe and one other person, I can't remember
who. We're all like parties. We're all like witnesses to some
of his abusive behaviors. Um Kuoku C. Oh, Ko. Yeah. Yeah. Cuko.
Cuo. Well, Kelly is friends with her. How do you say it, Kelly?
Cuko.
Cuko. Cuko. That person. I'm sorry. Sorry. Yeah, but those were
witnesses.
Yeah. To his abusive behavior.
Yeah. Written down. It doesn't mean that they're the only ones
though, right? Sometimes people just will put the top names that
they know of.
Sorry. I've not heard this. Where where was this released? Was
in the Shimu video. This was Oh, so in the Shimu video. Yeah.
There's two court filings. And this was for Pinky, right? Oh,
no. This was the um I think it was the ex-wife, but they were
witness to the ex-wife. Yeah, there were witnesses to the ex-wife.
I think that might have been in Pinkiey's filing that was talking
about the Google doc. Yes, frame. But I think that might have
been in Pinkiey's Google like filing that talked about the Google
doc and said the Google doc alleged these things. I think but
I'm not 100% sure on that. To speak about um what the the concern
about Frame was that made her feel like their lives were going
to be ruined.
Yep. Oh, I see.
I want to remind you I have met Minkx one time at the OTK Thanksgiving
Friendsgiving where I joined OTK. I have met her one time. Since
then I have lived with minimum a partner, a wife or a roommate
or a girlfriend throughout my entirety of living here. Never
once have I lived by myself. I have always had someone living
with me the entire time I've been down in Austin. And this woman
is so deranged that she thinks that I lived with her. Now I don't
know what gorgeous bald man with a beautiful beard she must be
having sex with on a daily basis and her STD
to Can he not imagine living with a woman if she's not a doll
for him? That's that's basically what he's saying. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, the way that he talks about women, he obviously
doesn't have a very high opinion of them, right?
True. It's like quite disgusting that he doubled down on the
stuff he said about denims. I don't know. Yeah. It's just like,
oh, these women are they're only good for being fans and are
good enough for listening to despite the fact that nothing like
cohesive or intelligent comes out of his mouth. But he doesn't
have the benefit of also being attractive. So, he's got neither.
But he is a man and he is loud
allegedly. What do you mean allegedly? You're not sure he's a
man.
Unless it comes out in a court document. I'm just going to air
on the side a caution to not defame. Not defame. Yeah. I don't
want to accuse him of being a man until like the courts determine
it or a jury of his peers. That truly is the biggest insult of
all time to call someone a man. Yeah. True. On a daily basis.
and her STD ridden to think that a toxic
How does he know her is so STD ridden? That's what I would like
to know. Yeah, I don't know. That's quite a claim, right? That's
defamatory.
Could be. Could definitely be defamatory. Yeah, sure.
It is uh it is it's literally harming her reputation, right?
Uh yeah. Yeah. I think I think actually I believe that's actually
defamation per se. If you accuse somebody of having an STD explicitly
that is def defamation per se. It's one of like the most common
cases because you're making them like a health risk to the people
around them.
This it's so funny that the reaction to all of these people Ethan
Klein uh Denims Tech for for defamation per se is for them to
immediately defame the other people they're talking about. They're
like they're they're unable to actually identify the fact that
like that how people have always talked on the internet and that
they shouldn't read that much into it. They just get their feelings
hurt, right? And they immediately go, "I'm going to sue you.
You're you're ruining my reputation."
But they and why is it just because celebrity drama has gotten
really huge with their court cases?
I don't know. Be the next Johnny Depp.
I don't know. I I actually have no idea. I I I did
I think I think it's that they now have enough money that like
the thought of a court case and they might be looking at how
defamation lawsuits have been used to like silent critics, right?
Like that's essentially you get enough money and you can start
using the courts as like a weapon against people because realistically
people even if they Jay-Z's girl like Jay-Z's girls exactly like
that is how a lot of people So I think Carl Jobs did this to
not Carl Jobs Billy Mitchell did this to somebody who basically
like he went and he sued them for defamation and I think to avoid
the court case that person just settled like they did they didn't
want to go to court they couldn't really go to court so they
just settled with him right and took like their videos down.
If people don't want to risk going to court with you and paying
a bunch of money in legal fees, they will sometimes just settle
with you. So, you can use defamation lawsuits as a way to like
try to chill speech against you. Yeah. Yep. So, that might just
be that he's got enough money now and Ethan's got enough money,
some of these people have enough money that they're willing to
try it out, see how it goes, which is pretty
stdritten to think that it's me. But I assure you, I have never
lived with this woman. I don't even know this woman outside of
a one-time interaction where there was 50 other streamers there.
Now, you might be wondering, why did I get banned for seven days
on twitch.tv/tech?
Oh, why did Twitch deem me?
Wait, I'm sorry. Isn't there an Australian streamer who did this
that we talked about last year? Carl Carl Jobston. Billy Mitchell.
Yeah. No. Yeah. Billy Billy Mitchell is the person who got sued
and Carl Jobs is the person who sued them. Uh oh. Is that somebody
that Chad Logic covered? I This is like an Australian YouTuber.
Yep. Does he have a YouTube name or is it literally
Carl Jobs? Tropes. Oh, that name sounds familiar, but okay. I
guess we're saying that talking about the same Dark Viper. Is
that his name? Oh, that is a different guy who threatened people.
I don't That's who I was thinking of. But that's who you're thinking
about. Okay. Yeah. Going back further. Yeah, you did say last
year. So, yeah, sure. Uh I don't know if that guy actually sued
anybody though. I think he just threatened and it was more DMCA
stuff with Chud, right?
Yeah. And someone else too, didn't he?
But he was like successful. People don't like Chud won't cover
his,
right? Yeah. But that's DMCA claims and that's because basically
like that would that would have to go to court, right? Like you
would be accepting. This is different. This doesn't have to do
with defamation. It's just this is a DM. It's sort of the same
concept though. No, no, no. They're like they I think they are
like basically the same concept. Using DMCAs to chill speech
against you, right? That basically people reacting to your stuff.
You're using DMCAs to chill speech against you versus this one
is like defamation. So basically even if people aren't reacting
to your stuff, the DMCA stuff would require them reacting to
you, right? And then you can DMCA them and say, "Let's go to
court because I don't think this reaction is legal." Because
I think the React content that he was hitting like it was transformative.
I don't know how
Yeah, that was very strange. It was transformative in terms of
we would accept it as transformative for most people, but there
is like the idea that realistically there's never been like the
current kind of React content to pursue it. Well, the current
kind of React content is basically never really been tried in
court because it's like in the it's literally in the gray area
where it's like not clear on any of the legs of DMCA law or whatever
or copyright law. Yeah. So, like it's not clear that it would
go either way and that's why most people don't want to go to
court on it because you basically would have to go and set the
precedent which would cost insane amounts of money in terms of
litigation fees, right? So, that's why Chud's just like, "Yeah,
it's like way too much money. I'm not going to do that. That's
not going to be my struggle." Right. Got it. That's why they
feel similar. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Worthy of a 7-day ban because
I called them. Yep. I called two women with only
I don't think that's actually exactly what you did.
You did the You talked about Mix's STDridden vagina. That's a
little further, but you're a bald white guy who wears white beers.
Bould you like, are we not tit for tat right now? Well, I think
that that is his point though, right? That we are tit for tat.
Yeah, he's like literally banan them or don't ban me, but don't
let them just call me a again. He has actual charges for this.
If he was just like I think I think it's also a little different
in that he's like and demeaning people, right? And Twitch does
just doesn't like that. Unfortunately, Twitch maybe you could
say are a little progressive and if you just straight up say
the only use for this woman is for me to come to her, like literally
to jerk off to her, like they're not going to like that. They
think that's bad.
This is actually I just realized that this video is talking about
his ban. For some reason, I thought this video was the reason
he got banned and uh it had to do with the STD comments because
that makes a lot more sense. I feel like his ban should be increased.
Hold on. Somebody posted a clip. What's the clip? How does he
know her is so STD ridden? Excellent clip. We'd love to see it.
What was What was the purpose of that?
I don't know. Somebody posted the
which is by the way by definition a factual statement.
Only fans girls who are workers are prostitutes. Prostitutes
are are prostitutes. Prostitutes are workers. I got banned for
two weeks for calling a fat person fat. I got banned for seven
days. Wow. for calling a a and now I'm sorry if that terminology
upsets you but the problem is that doesn't make it any less true
disping that out of defense. I'm only calling them that out of
defense because they have provoked me by a offendedly called
that woman fat.
It's Yeah, it's insane.
I Sorry. I was literally I was literally typing to Kelly two
seconds. Like you literally said that as I'm going to Kelly,
can you confirm that I was just asking you to add something on
the Discord? Uh yeah. While the video is running. Okay. I I'm
about to type the thing to you that I wanted you to do. Um one
second.
I don't know if they're even in the Discord actually now that
I think about it. Um,
okay. Sorry. We're continuing. Accusing me of crimes that I have
not committed
whatsoever going in on allegations that went nowhere almost a
year ago now. I think it's pretty reasonable if I call them a
name or two. So, I want to let you guys all know this. This is
the same website where Hassan calls Mia, where Hassan calls Naku
a who calls Mudahar a who calls Asmin Gold a and a mother killer
bringing up Asmin Gold's dead mother. No ban no punishment.
Yeah. Yeah, we could we could ban for that. Mike, that's the
case. PA calls me a calls Nux calls
Oh, you guys love Loi though. That's to most people on the internet.
That's
asigold. Calls him a murderer. No ban. Calls for the death of
Asmigold. No ban. Denims who has also called for the death of
Asthmagold. No ban. Hassan, who has radicalized his audience
to supporting terrorism, no ban. Froggen who supported 911. No
ban. I call an only fans girl a after she called me a
careerending lifeending
accusation. They get no punishment
again. Show me the evidence of them calling you a racist. Unless
you want to, unless he is admitting that actually, okay, actually
the assault thing, we get to call your dad because if somebody's
assaulted and you say that they're guilty of assault that you're
calling them. So either we're all correct for calling your dad
or you need to shut the up. One of the two. I get seven days.
We clear up what he sees as LO because he he techone claims that
he thinks Lo is uh well he plays a bunch of the games. So unfortunately
for him, if you make your life playing uh games that sell Lolly
characters in them, I I just don't feel that bad for you. Maybe
not.
Do we get why this is a problem now? Do we understand why this
is bad? And sure. Could you make the argument, well, he deserved
it? Sure.
Twitch, I wouldn't have to make these comments if you guys would
do your
job. If you guys were to ban people equally and fairly when they
cross the line, then I wouldn't think that I can do the same
thing as the rest of these
people. I suppose I'm a martyr.
I suppose I can once again get punished for the wrongdoings of
everybody else and maybe that will put the fear in them to get
their act together. I Does this guy have any mode other than
pure hardcore victim mode? No, I think that's just like the default
for a lot of men online right now.
I just I don't see it like he literally but like he's he's like
a harder victimizer than anybody. He's like 10xing on the victimization
like the self victimization. He's like 10xing what anybody else
is capable of. It's crazy. I Yeah. Anyway, but it won't because
these people Oh, wait. I can think of one person who's actually
in his league, but I'm not talking about you can get away with
these misdeeds, with these malpractices because you don't enforce
your toos fairly. You do not enforce your toos equally. And this
is why I will be streaming on kicking YouTube every single day
during this ban. Again, this is pathetic rat behavior. And Twitch,
I would like to let you know
now, 24 hours ago, I have already recruited over streamer. Am
I remembering this correctly? Was there a time on Twitch when
people acted like saying rat was like um a slur or something?
Calling someone a rat.
Oh, sure. The anti-semitism stuff. Like a dog whistle. The pig
dog.
It's like three years ago. Pig dog was on too. Then I don't Yeah,
I don't know about the rat thing. I I would assume that's an
anti-semitic thing. Bosch versus Mike from PA. Yeah, rat the
some of the rat stuff. People will take that as a slur against
Yeah, absolutely. So, is he threatening to like create a coalition
of all of the Jason content creators on Twitch and take them
off? Is that his move here?
I'm going to take all the VTubers and all the gotacha streamers
and we're going to a different platform. Now, unfortunately,
Twitch loves those VTubers, so it actually might be a credible
threat, but in terms of people I want around me, he's kind of
he's kind of offering to clean up. Unfortunately, he is offering
to bring them over to Kick, which is less than ideal. Okay. But
maybe Kick will like me more as a VTuber, you know? I'm like
VTuber adjacent. Yeah, you made me to be a VTuber. I did. Oh,
wait. Am I supposed to say that on here? Well, I think I just
think you can make a lot of money. But if you don't want to do
that, that's fine. I told Jerry she should just do the VTuber
thing.
Damn. Oh, where's the stream on YouTube and kick? Sounds really
It has now been 72 hours and I have now recruited over 110 creators
to stream on Twitch, YouTube, and Kick. This is not a good look
for you guys. This is
Is it not a horrible look?
I because they're multireaming. They should just multiream to
kick. Also, hold on. I missed the Asmin Gold tweet. Wait, wait,
wait. Where's the Asmin Gold tweet? Gold link says you have the
wrong type of autism to be a VTuber. And I just I actually want
him to go into depth about that. I'd love to hear him go into
depth into it, too. I want to like people. I do like people.
Where is this? I'm looking for the video right now, guys, of
Asmin Gold after two streams on kick because it was pretty crazy.
Is this JC would get along with
What's a Kers?
Kirish is a Vtuber.
Uh, I wouldn't get along with her. Kish. Yeah, kind of.
Oh my god. So easy to figure out. She makes like she makes like
racist jokes and some of her racist jokes are funny, but she
also is like a vaccine denier. So like I kind of just got no
patience, you know? No. You know, if you're going to be racist,
I understand, but you're going to deny the vaccine. I don't have
I don't have any patience for that type of ignorance. It's like
it's like race adjacent jokes. That's the thing. It's a big difference.
Yeah, it's a massive difference. Yeah, it's a massive difference.
I can't find this as gold tweet, so I'm just going to hit play.
You should be ashamed because you know this is unfair. You know
this is and you can't have a toos
where you do not enforce it equally amongst all creators. And
this is the reason why you guys are getting sued.
And now you guys know that these people in a court of law can
use me as an example of you guys unfairly once again misusing
your to. I call these women very disgusting as an insult when
they are giving me lifeending
careerthreatening allegations and
No, hold on. No, no, no, no, no. They're they're literally saying
they believe your girlfriend who's giving you life-ending career-ending
allegations and they're not even life-ending or career ending.
They suck. Certainly, I'm not saying that they should be thrown
around willy-nilly, but like the what is it? The waffles guy.
Who's what's his name? Uh wheat No, no. Wheat waffles is the
incel. Who's the guy who was the Minecraft streamer who actually
No, no, no. The Minecraft streamer who like actually did like
a giant waffle. Yeah, Giant Waffle is the guy who was he got
like actually convicted of gang rape, I believe, and he just
kept streaming and he was fine. Yeah, Giant Waffles. Yeah, you
just keep hitting that go live button. I don't know if he got
convicted. He just kind of admitted to it and then it went tried
to make it go away or something, right? Wasn't it like the story
that the person told he was like, "Yeah, that was pretty true."
And then just everyone I I feel like that was accurate. I don't
think he convicted. Oh, he wasn't convicted. Sorry. Deny it.
Yeah.
Ad you just defame you [__]
I don't like uh I don't think it's defamation. If you make a
mistake and retract it. Oh, okay. Yeah. If you retract it, but
like if people don't correct you,
why denims? I'm pretty sure even with defamation per se, you're
like, "Oh, you can send a message to the person be like, I need
you to correct this publicly." And I think I think basically
once they correct publicly, you're fine. Don't ever talk [__]
about denims. I'm going to remind you of this moment.
Uh, okay.
This is the reason why so many male creators have disappeared
over false allegations. You guys need to take this seriously.
It's pathetic and you guys should be ashamed. Now, I'm going
to be over here on YouTube and kick making way more money than
I ever made on your platform regardless. And Twitch, I want to
let you know in 3 days I have now made more money on kick than
I made in a month on streaming on Twitch. I do not give a about
the money that I'm losing on Twitch at all. I don't uh perfect.
Uh why did you just delete this? What are you gonna do about
it? What need it? I'm a multimillionaire. Sorry. Somebody sent
me the tweet and then they deleted it. However, so I'm confused.
Just understand, I'm not going away. And in seven days, I will
come back and I will continue to showcase the hypocrisy and the
blatant abuse of power being used by your moderation team that
is treating your streamer like unfairly besides the one you like.
You should be ashamed. The best way to get revenge if you are
upset on Twitch right now is to share this video, like this video,
subscribe to my channel, and be there every single time I go
live so I can be a constant reminder of how this platform keeps
on getting worse. What a Okay. I feel I feel like I never love
people who like make all of their living off of a platform and
then they've just got like no like dude,
don't ride that [__] into the ground forever. I don't
know. Like it's Anyway, 32,000 is what admin gold had made for
the past month on on Twitch.
But doesn't he literally shut ads off?
I don't think you can shut ads totally off anymore. So, he's
got an hour
Hold on. Yeah, he doesn't have ad breaks at all. Kick has
ad if you run ads on Twitch. This is so
stupid. That is true. That is actually totally true. Yes. Only
an hour and 50 minutes of ad breaks
over 210 hours streamed, right? So I think I think they force
some ads on, but yeah, you don't run ads normally. Ad time per
hour, 31 seconds. Okay.
32,000.
He should only be uh comparing it to what? 1 hour and 50 minutes
on kick.